la región de tests de woods vista desde
el aire en color marrón miles de
hectáreas de bosques quemadas se pueden
observar en esta foto de satélite tomada
hace dos días el resultado de una semana
de inusuales incendios el mismo lugar
antes de las llamas con la vegetación
intacta en el terreno el fuego sigue
cobrando factura ayer los bomberos
agotados fueron requeridos sin descanso
debido a nuevos focos revivió el fuego
está muy agresivo demasiado complicado
hay vientos en varias direcciones
desplazamientos dispositivos
constantemente es muy duro similar a más
de dos mil bomberos todavía están siendo
movilizados el fuego sigue avanzando
pero menos rápido que los días
anteriores
no hay nuestros bomberos en el terreno
necesitaban buenas noticias hoy tenemos
un respiro ellos lo sienten y eso los
motiva a salir sean jugadores
otro incendio 80 kilómetros más al este
en la región de la antiga también está
cediendo los bomberos tratan de sofocar
las llamas para proteger las casas
aledañas
los habitantes vinieron a echarles una
mano
ellos están cansados desde hace mucho
tiempo están combatiendo el fuego lo
mínimo es ayudarlos y agradecerles
este miércoles enmanuel mccomb visitar a
gijón para acompañar los equipos de
rescate en un comunicado el elíseo
respaldo el compromiso de las fuerzas
vivas de la nación en el combate contra
las llamas